from Cornell take it up
thanks to the organizers and thanks to
everyone watching here and everyone else
on YouTube watching it live
I'll be talking about statistical
inference under information constraints
uh we'll look we'll focus more on the
user level approaches towards the end of
the talk
this joint work with klema Johann zitang
and himanshu had put their pictures
before the talk so I don't spend too
much time on this slide now
so we'll talk about let's start with a
very basic problem of Bernoulli
estimation you have niid
draws from a coin with
biasp
and your goal is to estimate P okay
great you just sum the excise divide by
n
and show that the mean squared error of
estimation is p times 1 minus p over n
wonderful
just look at the same problem with a
slight paste
let's look at a distributed Bernoulli
estimation where these n coin tosses are
distributed across n users and each of
them can send one bit message
to some referee R now you'll say okay
you see one bit at each user and you
have to send a one bit message I each y
I can just be x i
nothing to do so you can do whatever
you're doing in the previous slide
okay so let's make it a little more
interesting
what if these n samples are distributed
across square root n users and each user
has square root and ID samples
but they're still restricted to sending
one bit messages
what happens these y eyes are still one
bit
and this referee wants to estimate the
underlying distribution how well can
they do it so this is sort of the
motivation for the talk now you can
either think about it
or wait for me to answer it later in the
progress was like the opening
so here's the outline of the talk will
motivate the problem give some precise
formulations talk about some some of the
oldest results that we have been working
on for the past three four years
primarily during covet so I don't I've
not given many talks on them so I'll try
to summarize some of those results and
then move to move to some of the new
results we have
okay
statistical inference you have a
collection of distributions over some
domain X
and you get niid samples
from some distribution P that belongs to
this class calligraphic Peak and you
want to solve some inference task okay
that's the highest level thing
in this talk we will primarily look at
discrete distributions we have some
results on other things but 35 minutes
is just not enough 350 Maybe
so
let P be the collection of all displayed
distributions over a domain of size K
and we'll be primarily working with
total variation distance so just think
of L1 distance
we'll look at two questions of Interest
first is estimation okay learning your
goal is to Output a p hat that says that
the expected distance from the true
distribution p is at most Epsilon
and a complementary task is of
hypothesis testing in this case we'll
just look at what we call as uniformity
testing
where U denotes the uniform distribution
over K elements
and your goal is to design a tester t
such that if p is equal to U if p is the
uniform distribution you output 0 with
probability at least 0.9 if the distance
of P from uniform is at least Epsilon in
the total variation distance
then you want to Output a 1 it's
probably point nine so this testing
Sorry learning and testing
but I have phrased this that okay you
get to see xn the true samples and then
you want to do these tests
what we want to look at is
the case when you do not get to see the
exact samples Okay so
you get you have only a limited amount
of information about these exercises
for example you may have communication
constraints each of the sample may be
maybe you have to describe them using at
most L bits
or maybe privacy constraints where you
cannot disclose the underlying samples
and they have to be somehow privatized
remember this exercise belong to some
high dimensional space and you want to
project them into a low dimensional
space and that's what you get to observe
model these local information
constraints on the channels uh sorry on
the samples
so the framework will be that there are
n users
user t gets to observe x t one IID
sample from the underlying distribution
p and they get to send a message YT
we can model this as a channel WT where
the input is the sample at a user the
output is the message that you get to
see
once the channel is fixed because the
input distribution is p of X the output
distribution is just given by p x times
the transition probabilities of the
channel
so what the way we will model these
local information constraints is by
specifying a set of allowed channels
calligraphic W and each user is bound to
pick
one channel or their messaging scheme
from this set of allowed skills
this is how the picture will look like
you have a distribution and IID samples
each sample passes through a channel you
get to see the
outputs of the channel and then your
goal is to solve the same inference task
as you did before
and maybe now you will require more data
because of data processing
what kind of constraints one can think
about the easiest will be communication
constraints when the set script W is
constrained to channels whose output is
at most L bits long or let's say l bits
so each x t has to be mapped to an L bit
string
or local differential privacy starting
with the works of Warner and there have
been many many new works on local
privacy although in this Workshop I did
not see that many Works presentations on
local privacy except maybe I first talk
today
and I'm going to call it as row ldb
so we have used Epsilon
okay we
and the good thing is although
we'll present some results on privacy I
think the communication one is easier to
communicate and privacy is harder to
describe clearly right okay so we will
consider uh
Channel W is called row ldp If the ratio
of if for any input x and x Prime and
any output y the ratio of these
transition probabilities is bounded by e
to the row so you can get confused about
the input
and we'll focus on the setting where the
row is a small so e to the row is one
plus Epsilon now what is the question
that we want to do
I claim that once you specify the
channels the job is done because once
you specify the channel the output
distribution is just the product of each
of the output distributions at the at
the users because the input distribution
is IID
all the users have X1 X and IID once you
specify the messaging scheme W1 through
WN the output distribution the output
distributions of the messages are
independent so the entire question
becomes how do we optimally choose W1
through WN namely how does one decide
the messaging schemes
okay now here comes the interesting
partner what kind of Freedom do we have
in choosing the channels the easiest or
the simplest case is when all the
channels are chosen simultaneously
namely all the messages are sent out at
the same time
so there is no interaction
even here something interesting can be
asked okay
there is a distinction between private
coin and public coin assembly let me
just specify what it is so in the
private coin SMP all the users just
independently choose their messaging
schemes the easiest way to think is I
fix the channels ahead of time w12wn are
fixed
so in this case all the messages are
independent of each other
slightly more involved setting would be
what's called as public coin SMP where
there is a shared Randomness that's
available to all the users
and the users can now choose their
channels WTS as a function of this
shared randomness
so now the messages are not independent
of each other however they are
independent conditional
the shared randomness
so pictorial is what you look like you
have now a shared Randomness across the
users and that's how the channels can be
chosen
you can make it a little more
complicated you can say okay
what if there is interaction
in this case again there is shared
Randomness but now the messaging happens
sequentially maybe I'll just go directly
to the picture
so first the first user chooses a W1
sends their message now the second user
gets to see this message that the
previous guy has sent and then they
choose their Channel based on that and
so on so each player chooses their
Channel as a function of the shared
Randomness and all the previous messages
so arguably in terms of implementation
the private coins
no communication no interaction is the
easiest to implement
public coin will be maybe a little more
complicated and interactive protocols
will have like the latency and other
kinds of issues and the question here
would be
is it worth going into
more complicated skins statistically
like do you gain something by doing that
okay
let's look at some of the results we
have
uh on discrete distributions like the
two questions that I asked before okay
for estimation under total variation
distance where your goal is to Output a
p hat that's Epsilon close to the true p
uh the sample complexity or the number
of samples you need to solve it is given
by K Over Epsilon Square where K is the
domain size Epsilon is the accuracy you
want
upper bound just take the empirical
distribution lower bound apply for now
okay so information Theory almost 101
for testing you can actually do
something slightly better you can do it
with square root K Over Epsilon Square
samples you need fewer samples there are
hundreds okay now sorry tens of papers
proposing different kinds of schemes to
do that
and the lower one is basically inkster's
method that from like it is most of
these things just are beautiful variants
of voting star said way back in 80s I
think and so for example gives one nice
construction for how to apply it for
this specific case
you just look at communication
constraints for now I will talk a little
bit about privacy buckets
later
so these messages are constrained to be
L bits long now I'll say okay what if L
is more than log k then there is nothing
to do
because you have only a k the domain
size is K if I have more than log K bits
to communicate I'll just send whatever I
have
so that's why most of the this part is
at least interesting when L is small
and the first result that we talk about
is
this so you had K Over Epsilon Square
which was the sample complexity without
communication constraints now there is
this blow up of times K over 2 to the L
so that's the penalty that you have to
pay
and once L is locked here this is one
and this is true for communication
protocols you do not gain anything by
share Randomness not even by
interactivity
so for example when L is one
you have a quadratic law like instead of
K A non Unit K Square
samples
but testing actually the scene is a
little more interesting
for private coins simultaneous message
passing you get the same blow up okay K
Over Q to the L
but if you have some shared Randomness
you can do something much better now
instead of K Over tutorial the blow up
is square root of K over 2 to the L
so in other words with one bit
communication you pay linear in K
instead of
three over two in terms of a number of
samples so just the power of shared
Randomness for a very simple task of
estimating of testing discrete
distributions
so this uh
is uh this testing work is from paper
from cold and then it is in transactions
so in one slide I can write it all the
results about communication constraints
so for estimation
private coin public coin interactive no
Gap
here there is a gap but interactivity
doesn't buy you anything beyond shared
Randomness for testing
okay and for estimation path uh results
were independently obtained by Han osgor
and Wiseman
this point
same thing can also be done for
differential privacy qualitatively all
the results hold true
you gain something for testing under ldp
with
shared Randomness nothing beyond that
all these three are identical
okay so that's all the results we have
for
local privacy
for testing I think these results were
obtained simultaneously by many people
including like Amin Mao Joseph and
Barrett and bhuticia
and some of the results for estimation
were proved when I say sum
I mean proving lower bounds for
non-interactive schemes
for estimation was proven in Duty Jordan
Wainwright
I think the claim interactive results
but the proof well it doesn't go through
what's new today I'll talk so this was a
recap of all the things that we did for
many many years yes
can you give us the intuition why public
coin for testing helps and yes it
doesn't help her
yes
you want you let's say this is your
uniform distribution
and your goal is to separate the uniform
from an L1 ball let me just draw a
circle
so when you have when you don't have
shared Randomness the people have fixed
their schemes ahead of time
and now what the adversary can do is to
choose let's say you are
when you have shared Randomness what you
can do is randomly pick a Direction
and then with high probability let's say
this is the true underlying distribution
it's a min max versus maximum question
okay who gets to go first when you have
shared Randomness you are going to
choose the channel after I choose the
choose the distribution in the other
case I get to choose the distribution
and you get to fool me
so for example if I choose the
distribution here what you will do is
once I let's say I select the channels
then you will choose a distribution
that's going to fool my channel so that
I'm not able to distinguish between the
the two distributions on the other hand
if I if if you get to go first then I
randomly basically I'll randomly pick uh
some kind of Channel that's going to
with high probability give me some
information about the true thing
and generally this for for most of these
things we actually have lower bounds for
General set of channels so you take a
setup Channel The calligraphic W then we
come up with a positive summative Matrix
that somehow gives some characteristics
of those matrices and all these things
that you see there are various Norms of
those matrices that appear in this
equation so there is a trace Norm here
there is a frobenius norm here there is
the operator Norm times the
press knob here and all of those things
when specialized to these things just
give the type Point somehow
so what happens when you have multiple
samples per user okay that's called user
level constraints so the top will be
based on these two these two recent
works one reason to one not so
so what is user level information
constraint you have
instead of one sample so previously we
we call it sample level results why
sample level each sample was transferred
into a message
now it will be each user can have more
than one sample and that has to be
converted into a message so here for
example each user has M samples
and the total communication budget is
still L okay so even if they get to see
many more things
we can only send L bits per user so now
there is this tension of some sorts
right you have more samples so maybe you
can do more processing but you don't
have
maybe enough bits to send what you have
processed so that's the kind of question
we want to understand here so here uh W
the channel from embed sample from M
samples to zero one to VL exact same
thing can also be stated for
differential privacy where now when you
take the ratio you can replace all the M
samples of the user by something else
and this condition must be Obed
okay
we want to again look at discrete
distribution estimation
but instead of sample complexity because
the results look very ugly okay so we
are going to consider we will express
some of the results in terms of rates
I'll come to this so let's not worry
about it until I come back
let's go back to the beginning of the
talk a second
the beginning of the talk I said let's
look at Bernoulli estimation
so that means underlying alphabet sizes
2 and each user has only one bit to send
all right so this is end users each has
mid sample so so the observation at each
user is just a binomial random variable
binomial MP they get M samples from
and samples from one only P so they get
to see binomial MP
and each user just sends a one bit
message
your goal is to estimate P that was the
that was the first slide
all these M times and samples are
present
one location you'll just do whatever we
suggested in the very beginning you'll
get this in square error
but now the question is how can we or
what can we do in a distributed setting
where let's say these n samples are
distributed across square root and users
and each user can still send only one
bit
foreign
estimation
for example the easiest attempts would
be
I guess if you just decide to send one
of your samples that's not wise because
you have so many samples you'll just
take a factor of M loss so you don't
want to do that
maybe each user will tell you if there
are more zeros or ones
okay let's start with that
the problem is if the true p is away
from half let's say it's a fourth or
three quarters then you will be seeing
all those are all ones from most people
just by concentration
however
somehow this true p is close to a half
to one or two standard deviation that's
why I wrote plus or minus one over root
M so each user has a binomial M comma P
so their standard deviation is about
square root M right so if P belongs to
half plus or minus square root M then
what can we do
our goal is to get to 1 over square root
of M times n
so can we just somehow transform from
here actually the answer is yes
what we will do is if you already know
that P is between half plus or minus 1
over root M then each user is just going
to Threshold at half if I see less than
M over two samples I'll send 0 if I see
more than m
if I see more less than M over to zeros
I will send 0. 1 I'll send one otherwise
I will send 0. so
and what will you do you have aggregated
all of this you will just invert the
binomial CDF Act
and that will be enough it's just like
think of quantizing a gaussian to
estimate the mean you even if you
quantize to one bit and invert the cdfs
you'll get the tight bounce of two order
factors okay something very similar here
okay so what does technique
that we are able to estimate
estimate to
Factor we are able to boost it up
somehow
so a two-step approach would be for
somehow come up with a course estimate
for p
and then do a refinement by thresholding
at your course estimate
so in other words
okay if we do this I think this is the
result that will aim for this first term
is what you get when you have all the
samples at one place the second term is
actually somehow necessary imagine this
the second term tells you that n
shouldn't be too small why because
imagine all the samples are at one user
but they have only one bit to send
nothing to do right you need at least
some users that will give you some more
than one bit okay so that's what this
term captures that and N can't be one or
two it has to be more than
something
so now with the with interactivity wait
wait
the titles of this should have been just
interactivity
okay
so with interactivity now the scheme can
be it's pretty natural to implement
right okay so we'll first come up with
the course estimate by just doing a
binary search okay so you start with
let's say a thresholding at M over two
you keep seeing a bunch of zeros so you
go to Threshold at M over four maybe at
one fourth keep doing it until you get a
rough estimate of P and then you just
threshold that that
place
so the the most interesting part of this
work was actually to come up with
non-interactive estimate that that's
able to do these reasonably intuitive
steps that we saw how to implement all
of those things
without interaction
so that's not I'll just discuss a little
bit now
till the course estimate part is not
that complicated we'll see
so
what was our goal our goal was to
estimate each estimate the P up to a
standard deviation around its uh True
Value right so what we start off with is
take 0 through M that's the set of
observations that have a person can have
they can see from a single one or sorry
from zero ones all the way up to M1
that's what each user sees they just get
m
samples right
so we partition this interval into
roughly square root M intervals that are
growing in size up to a half because
that's
so the width at of each of these
interval is growing linearly order I and
that's roughly the standard deviation
so if if if M times p is in a particular
interval that standard deviation will be
roughly the width of the interval
that's what uh what to do
so maybe we can first set aside some
users that are going to
send one bit information about which
interval they are in okay there are many
ways to do it I think the cleanest
approach that actually at least I think
is the cleanest approach is to just use
a gray code to specify these intervals
and just send bits for the gray code
and this was also used in anxiety and
way for gaussian estimation
if nothing I think most of you know gray
code if not maybe that's the one thing
that you can learn from the talk
so what's a gray code gray code is a
binary representation of numbers from
zero so what's the mistake here
zero up to
minus 1.
okay we test big so the the nice
property here is uh if you go if you
look at two consecutive numbers they
differ in exactly one bit so now if we
assign this to the intervals if you make
a mistake in estimation you are just
going to end up in an interval that's
adjacent to you okay you want to end up
across the country or something
so now that's the first step so you
you have come up with a partition of the
intervals you first take a subset of the
users that you are going to just use for
this course estimate for the first step
to partition them into s groups
each group is now just going to look at
the interval that their sample Falls in
and send the jth bit of the gray code
representation of that interval number
basically
and we'll just take a majority
and finally whatever you end up with is
your is your course interval okay so
that you do with half of the users now
you have a course estimate
how do we do refinement without
interaction so now you have a course
estimate if you just have one more if if
you can just send that information to
everyone else
your goal then you can just threshold
there so how do we do that without
interaction
clearly the the course threshold could
be anywhere in this entire range right
what we will do is to just use multiple
thresholds
so we'll come up with some kind of
pulses this is very close to the same
interval scheme that we saw before
and if the number of ones that you have
false in the red things you are going to
send one otherwise you'll send a zero
this actually almost works
there is one very nice
sad thing that happens
which is if the true P falls in the
middle of an enter so so why do you what
are we trying to do okay we are somehow
going to use the information that we
have from the first half to get a course
estimate of P then we want that when P
so so now let's say we know which
interval p is what you want is when you
when the P changes you are able to
detect it by thresholding
okay that's the whole thing right you
are trying to invert a binomial CDF when
can you in work when actually changing
the parameter changes your distribution
That You observe otherwise you don't see
anything if I change the parameter and
what I am seeing has the same
distribution I don't see anything
I need just a couple more okay we have a
lot of time
suppose your p is in the middle of the
interval
I'm on slide number 44. oh it's here I
can see the upper bound so I have no
idea it's less than 60.
yeah 30 minutes so roughly two two per
minute right okay but what if what if p
is exactly in the middle of the interval
if p is exactly at the center of one
interval then you move p a little bit to
the right you are going to lose some
Mass on the left you are going to gain
some on the right if you move it a
little bit to the left you're going to
gain some on the left and loop sum on
the right so essentially when P changes
around the center of an interval you
will not be able to detect it quickly
it's almost like the first order of
you know you want you want to invert a
function right so if you want to invert
you want
you want it to have a behavior like this
so that if you change the parameter you
can detect it on this axis
but if you change the parameter and the
what you this is what you see and this
is the parameter
if it's flat you can't invert it that's
it okay and that's what happens if the
two parameter is in the middle okay so
what do you do you come up with another
fix
what's the fix here the fix is
just take another set of intervals
that are just these things shifted by
half of and over
then what you can show is
regardless of the value of P at least
one in one of these changing the P
changes the distribution of the
Threshold at the CDF or the quantize
outputs at least one in one of these
cases the derivative will be large you
take that invert the binomial CDF
and you get your
so this
is all the work that we have to do to
get a one bit
estimator for a Bernoulli random
variable when there are multiple samples
per user
okay so what do we do with it now we
want to extend it to carry distribution
people so now let's recall to estimated
distribution of the total variation
Epsilon you need K Over Epsilon Square
samples
now for some reason I don't want to
write results like this so what I do is
I want to write the results in terms of
TV error you'll see why
so the same thing you equate this to n
and then write Epsilon in terms of K and
N you get this okay that's the math
so for m equal to 1 this is the result
that we started off with the blow up in
Sample complexity instead of just this n
now you have to deal with this K over 2
to the L factor that I said in the very
beginning
what can we say when instead of m equal
to 1 there are multiple samples per user
can we do something as if
something nice okay let's see
so first result is that when m is not
too big when m is less than K over 2 to
the L
and N is
reasonably large and large we need for
some reason
then this is the optimal sample
complexity up to a constant orders
so in other words having
each user has M samples and sends L bits
it's the same as if you have M times n
users and each user sends L bits again
so so where are we gaining or losing
right so the the point is if you have M
times n users and each user sends just L
bits they have only one bit so they
can't really do anything Smarter with
all the samples that they have
so that's the the takeaway here that
it's as if you have M times and users
but each can send an albit message so
you need a lot more communication okay
and for the other regime we have some
results I want to just say that they are
tied up to log factors but there is
something nice that happens this 2 to
the L again you get actually it happens
only when m is small once M becomes too
big
you don't get much of a benefit
you don't get the exponential benefit
that you would want okay
there are some intuitions for that we
can talk later
let's give a sketch for okay how do we
boost this algorithm like we we did all
the work for binomial maybe we can just
finish by extending it to General k a
little bit very simple sketch the
algorithms are not that complicated I
think all the work goes into lower bound
but lower Bond as I said we'll need 350
minutes that I don't have
so what we do is you first partition K
into K over 2 to the L blocks each block
is of size 2 to the L Y 2 to the L
because if I know the block
I have enough bits to send which sample
I'm seeing or or at least one sample
within that block
Step One is we'll just consider these K
over 2 to the L blocks and look at the
distribution induced over the blocks by
T
so now your alphabet size has reduced to
from K to K over 2 to the L
what we'll do is just take half of the
users that you have
and divide them into B groups into the
number of groups that's the block so
each each person is responsible for one
block
uh sorry each of these small groups is
responsible for one block so what they
do is just run the one bit protocol
to estimate their block probability
so take half of the users to estimate
the probability over the blocks
and divide those users into how many
other blocks you have each user just
sees the sample sees the samples and for
them the only question is is it in the
block that I am responsible for or not
and they use the one bit scheme
in the second case you are going to
compute conditional distribution you do
again very similar thing you divide the
rest of the users into groups
and what those users will do is just
check their first sample
if it is in that block they are going to
send its binary representation otherwise
they'll just send maybe nothing
this is very interesting the first half
the users are just going to use one bit
out of the L they are not going to use
anything
in the second half the users are just
going to use one sample even if they
have M samples and somehow this doing
these two things which are in themselves
sub-optimal turns out to be the optimal
thing to do
yes so first half of the user will just
send a one bit even if they have L bits
second half of the users have M samples
each but they will look at only one
sample
and you combine these two things and
looking at all the results that we have
proved until now
I think you should be able to derive
this result okay just given whatever we
have proven until now let me just go
through
as I said lower bounds are hard for
these things and I think half of our
time out of those three years went in
realizing that many of the the lower
bonds claimed in other papers didn't go
through so first we got some of these
lower bonds we are very happy then we
said oh okay let's see if we can
rederive those things and why are they
getting stronger bonds than us
I mean and
turns out that
you can look at this paper We complain a
lot about many of the other works if you
are if you if you like having fun with
such things
thank you
[Applause]
for a question
Who's online yeah
yes
the final estimator of bias
is the finalist
is this estimate or biased or unbiased I
think it's definitely biased the way we
are doing especially with inverting the
the binomials we have
I have a comment it goes back to that
last slide uh where you said some lower
we observed similar things in our gas
context but I will ask you a broader
question
can you ever do any other F Divergence
phrase
my metric distance is to get any lower
bonds so one second
will go through
not just with L1 distance
so
further results go through because we
spent a lot of time on communication but
privacy also you can get results with
similar techniques and
maybe a little more of the messy work
that we have to do
okay do you have any uh sense of how
like um the the bandwidth scale with
Dimension so if instead of user had you
know D or M samples of like Dimension D
yes because now the blocks in those
cases yes so there is a lot of work so
the easiest question to ask is okay
let's say you have a three-dimensional
gaussian option standard covariance you
want to estimate the mean up to L1
distance uh L2 distance Epsilon but now
let's say they are distributed across
results each user gets to send one break
so Again Naturally if you just
user law of D instead of B over Epsilon
Square which you will get if all the
samples are at the same place you add
them up divided by n you get D over
Epsilon square that will become d square
over Epsilon Square
however
the lower bounds are interactive even
for that simple question I believe is
open it was claimed in a work of like
government and Woodruff
but I think the lower one breaks there
also so even for this basic question we
do not know what the answer is just
gaussian distribution distributed one
Bitcoin user
uh our next speaker is online
um
doesn't need much of an introduction